هكذا انتهت عطله نهايه الاسبوع في اسطنبول
انفجار يهود شارع الاستقلال الشهير وسط
المدينه يوقع قتلى وجرحى لتغلق السلطات
التركيه على اثره المكان
تفرض السلطات حظرا على نشر الاخبار بشان
الحادثه
لتداول بعدها صور تشير الى المشتبه بها في
تنفيذ الهجوم
تحصل الجزيره على صور خاصه
لاحقا روايه رسميه التي اشارت الى جلوس
المشتبه بها لاربعين دقيقه بالقرب من
المكان ومغادرته قبل التفجير بلحظات
الرئيس التركي اردوغان كان اول من اعطى
الارقام الاولى عن ضحايا الهجوم وتوعد
بالقصاص من الفاعلين تملا التلفزيون
الانجليزي
عقابهم والارهاب لن يصل الى هدفه والعناصر
التي حاولت النيل من الوحده التركيه لن
تصل الى مرادها لقد اطلعني ولي اسطنبول
على اعداد القتلى والجرحى وهذه الارقام
يمكن ان ترتفع تقفل السلطات مداخل الشارع
كافه وتكسف من اجراءاتها الامنيه في الحي
وتتشكل خليه ازمه من وزيري الداخليه
والعدل ونائب الرئيس التركي تتوجه للمكان
وتعلن عن ارتفاع عدد ضحايا
نستطيع الان تاكيد اننا نتعامل مع مشتبه
بها ويمكننا القول ان هذا الهجوم ارهابي
تتم الان مراجعه تسجيلات التي التقطتها
كاميرات مراقبه والفرق العامله في التحقيق
الجنائي تعمل باقصى طاقتها خصصت السلطات
التركيه خمسه من المدعيين العامله للتحقيق
في الهجوم لكنها حتى الان لم تشربي اصبع
الاتهام الى اي جهه وان كان في الحادث
اوصاف وبصمات تشابه هجمات سابقه كشف عن
الجهه المنفذه لها لكن يبدو ان السلطات
تفضل التريثات على الاقل حتى الان
عما تمر به البلاد سواء اقترابها من
استحقاق للانتخابي او حربها المستمره على
ما تسميه التنظيمات الارهابيه لكن
المسؤولين الاتراك يقولون انهم سيتمكنون
من معاقبه هنا ويؤكدون ان مثل هذه الهجمات
لن تكسر عزيمه الدوله التركيه او قوتها
عمر الحاج الجزيره اسطنبول